[Aplausos]
si tuviéramos que
pensar
en una palabra
cómo está el mundo al día de hoy
qué palabra pensaría
no me lo digan porque esté un té toque
pero piensen
pero seguramente dirían caótico
maravilloso complejo retador
diversos / polarizado etcétera
la verdad las cosas que es que vivimos
en un mundo interconectado
muy complejo porque cuando resuelves
algo en otro lado puedes tener alguna
especie de efectos no deseados
las soluciones no son tan simples como
pareciera que fueran
les quiero comentar tres conceptos
filantropía responsable social y
sustentabilidad y luego me voy a la
parte de los ejemplos
filantropía tiene mucho que ver la parte
de donaciones muy muy ligadas a
generalmente la empresa recursos
económicos y no están relacionadas
necesariamente con la organización
esta canción habla de una calle en
liverpool la calle encierro en la calle
típica y habla la canción de lo que pasa
a la gente saluda el barbero etcétera lo
interesante es el nombre de la calle que
fue hecha en honor de un señor llamado
james penny que murió a finales del
siglo 18
y james penny era el mayor filántropo de
esa época
dar dinero a casa su hogar ancianos
mujeres este niño sin escuela era el don
en ese entonces de los asuntos
filantrópicos
y también el mayor esclavista por un
lado soy el buen éxito
y por otro lado estoy depredando
en muchas ocasiones el negocio la
filantropía no tienen relación alguna el
segundo concepto que les quiero poner es
el tema de responsabilidad social y
significa como las personas
respondemos ante lo que causamos social
económica y este
y ambientalmente por lo que decidimos
hacemos o dejamos de hacer y se los
pongo con algunos ejemplos
alce la mano que le gusta el café
café negro
el capuchino
descafeinado
con unción de caramelo
con una dona para que llamara
con quién consumen café o con quién
consumimos café
solos amigos pareja familia compañeros
de trabajo compañeros de la universidad
etcétera donde consumimos café
la universidad en tu casa
cafeterías hoteles tiendas
alce la mano quién de ustedes fue a
pedir un café al lugar que haya sido la
última vez y le pide la persona que los
atendió me da un café sin trabajo
infantil
deme un capuchino que respete derechos
humanos
démosles press cortado que empoderan
mujeres empobrecen chiapas
no lo hacemos si quiero que sepan que
muchos del café que ustedes y yo hemos
tomado en nuestra vida tiene trabajo
infantil
la primera pregunta es lo sabías
la segunda pregunta es que importa la
tercera pregunta es qué haces para
cambiar esa realidad
otro ejemplo alce la mano quien se viene
un coche en automóvil para llegar aquí
que trajo coche
cuántos kilómetros manejaron vamos a
pensar 6 kilómetros de su casa
cuando contaminaron para estar aquí en
la sesión de texto que aquí en la
universidad
alguien lo mire
un coche bien afinado cuatro cilindros
en la ciudad de mexico con tráfico
moderado contamina doscientos mil cinco
gramos de co2 por kilómetro recorrido
quien llegó a esta universidad dijo
contamine seis kilos de co2
y hay un impacto
/
lo que hacemos decidimos en este caso el
transporte que utilizamos y la este y lo
que causamos al medio ambiente
cuántos clásicos yo solo uso consumen a
la semana
algo que usas unos minutos deshechas y
se degrade cientos de años
eres consciente te importa qué haces
para cambiar eso
y el último ejemplo para continuar
todos tenemos un smartphone
dentro de estos aparatitos hay un
mineral se llama coltán
y cortar se extrae del congo en su
mayoría y muchas minas del congo
hay tribus armadas que las controlan y
esclavizan a hombres mujeres y niños
para extraer el mineral
están en condiciones de esclavitud y lo
si quieren no dormirá esta noche busquen
en youtube mineral con flix congo y se
van a dar cuenta
que luego se mandan a un país en asia y
se hacen unos productos que fueron
diseñados en otro país
cuando ustedes manden un falso piensa en
el número de niños esclavizados
eso es responsabilidad social como
respondemos ante nuestras acciones
social ambiental y económicamente
el tercer concepto sustentabilidad
es como esta generación los 7200
millones que habitamos este planeta
satisfacemos nuestras necesidades y
compromete la capacidad de generar redes
futuras a satisfacer las suyas
siendo mucho más coloquial
sustentabilidad significa como no nos
acabamos el planeta
eso significa sustentabilidad y en esta
generación
y somos la primera generación que está
poniendo en riesgo al planeta nosotros
lo que pasa es que como lo dividimos
entre siete mil doscientos millones
pues total es el de enfrente no
tiene que ver por supuesto con la parte
económica pero también con la parte del
planeta y también con la parte de las
personas y cuando los tres convergen es
cuando se dice que tienes proyectos
sustentables
aquí le corresponde a ser responsable
al gobierno a las empresas a la sociedad
a todos o ninguno
a todos
y ese deporte nacional de culpar al de
enfrente
gobierno empresas empresas al gobierno
sociedad a todos ellos y culpas al de
enfrente y qué pasa que cambia de la
realidad
y luego por donde empiezas empiezas por
ti y tu círculo cercano y luego la
empresa cadena de valor empieza a
empezar a usar el planeta y luego te vas
a tu país y comunidad base del desafuero
se jode afuera hacia adentro
de adentro hacia afuera
en las empresas conducir sica
responsable social inicia con la
responsable social de la persona
no hay empresa socialmente responsable
si no hay personas socialmente
responsables dentro de las
organizaciones
eso es un reloj
ahí están las manecillas de los sus
horarios hagan de cuenta que ese que es
ese reloj en nuestro esquema de
pensamiento todos por donde nacemos cómo
crecemos este la familia con el que nos
criamos la comunidad donde estudiamos
etcétera no es un esquema de pensamiento
y lo que encaje en ese esquema de
pensamiento lo aprueba si lo que no
encajan los rechazos
ahora díganme qué es esto
es el mismo reloj con toda la maquinaria
y cuando pides a niveles de
sustentabilidad pasas de pensar así
a pensar así
porque si tú ves te tomas un café y de
repente te lo sirve alguien que los dos
todo lo molió y lo sirvió y llegó
alguien que lo transportó y lo compró y
el acopio y hay un pequeño productor de
café que está muriéndose de hambre él y
su familia porque solo le tocaron de una
tasa de 40 personas tocaron 32 centavos
cuando ves el mundo así esta persona ya
tiene una relevancia para tus decisiones
pero cuando no está presente pues
claramente no
empieza a ver otras cosas diferentes a
las que antes veías para el final el
mundo es mucho más grande de lo que
nosotros nos imaginamos y hay cuatro
clases de comportamiento está el
comportamiento inactivo
a mí no me importa total del mundo
escribiré por también es el reactivo
hay que llamar
está el proactivo oye te invito sí claro
vamos es el activo y es el por activo
bien y en este tema los agentes de
cambio están parados aquí
como las dos personas que me precedieron
en el texto y las que y las que siguen
que ahorita pude convivir con ellas y
pues son al final agentes de cambio que
no esperan a que alguien les diga qué
hacer si no están cambiando en sus
ámbitos de influencia una realidad de
manera positiva
y es lo que necesita el mundo agentes de
cambio buscando el bien común tanto en
personas como en negocios como en el
medio ambiente esta es una gráfica del
espectro síntesis index de el número de
personas preocupadas por el cambio
climático el año pasado pero lo
interesante es méxico de cada 100
personas a 93 no les importa el cambio
climático
día 7 sí
el mensaje es un largo camino por
recorrer
término que me quedan algunos minutos
con dos ejemplos reserva de la biosfera
de calakmul
en campeche y en medio de la selva en
medio de la selva hay estos contenedores
de agua
aunque la tierra es húmeda los animales
no tienen que beber
hay una foto que todavía no me han hecho
llegar pero que hay un jaguar dos
venados y tapires tomando agua de aquí
y no se atacan porque tienen sed
pues cada vez que usamos de más el coche
cada vez que utilizamos una botella de
plástico que no necesitamos cada vez que
compramos un par de zapatos que no
necesitamos cada vez que tenemos un
comportamiento usando popotes estamos
contribuyendo a eso
estuve también hace muy poco en el mar
de cortez me llevaban a ver un proyecto
de perlas sustentables y yo le
preguntaba al empresario una empresa de
30 años la única empresa en
latinoamérica que tiene este proyecto de
perlas sustentables
le decía cuál es tu mayor preocupación
que es lo que te quite el sueño a ti
como empresario
y yo pensé que me iba a comentar
inseguridad algún tema de crimen
organizado este la zona es no no es no
es la más segura en el país y tal y su
respuesta fue el cambio climático
ha subido 1.5 grados el mar de cortez y
si sobre un grado más van a desaparecer
todas las ostras del mar de cortez
y mi negocio va a desaparecer y esperan
que eso pase entre 5 y 8 años
si ves el mundo en tu relojito pues eso
que pero si lo ves con la maquinaria
completa empieza a tomar sentido
vivimos como si no fuera a pasar nada
y si pasa lo veamos o no estemos cerca o
no
esa es la agenda 2030 y la referencia
mundial que hay en este actualmente está
la norma iso 26000 está la comunicación
con el gris sin embargo la agenda 2030
es la que ha marcado la pauta para
muchas organizaciones gobiernos empresas
y sociedad para moverse los invito a que
conozcan lo que implica los 17 o de esas
y cómo pueden sumarse en su cotidianidad
y al final todos somos corresponsables
de construir un mundo más armónico e
incluyente y les pongo dos tres ejemplos
personales
hace hace algún tiempo mi esposa que
está aquí presente que llevó a casa un
este un aparato para filtrar el agua
hace poco porque cambiar el filtro
y cuando se cambia el filtro veía ahí
que se cambia cuando se agotan los 1500
litros que tiene de vida útil el filtro
bueno 1500 litros es el equivalente a
4200 botellas de plástico de 355
mililitros
es lo que dejamos de consumir una
familia de cuatro
en 20 meses
por solo comprar un aparato que nos
filtra el agua
otro ejemplo personal
yo antes tenía un coche ocho cilindros
una camioneta grande para no hacer
comerciales no digo la marca era una
camionetota ahora manejo un scooter de
125 centímetros cúbicos baje 97 por
ciento mis emisiones de co2
y me estoy ahorrando 35 mil pesos de
gasolina al año y 8 horas de tráfico en
la semana
y llegó hasta un poco de mejor ánimo
todos somos corresponsables en construir
una sociedad más armónica e incluyente
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]